ملف الاسرى يفتح من جديد اعلنت كييفو
موسكو عن عمليه تبادل جديده للاسرى هي
الثانيه خلال العام الجاري قالت اوكرانيا
ان روسيا افرجت عن 116 جنديا بالاضافه الى
جثث قتلى من المتطوعين الاجانب تمكن من
اعاده 116 من ابناء شعبنا من المدافعين عن
ماريوبول والمحاربين من خرسون وقناص من
جبهه بخموت وغيرهم من ابطالنا الشجعان
بدورها اعلنت موسكو عوده ثلاثه وستين من
جنودها وصفت بعضهم بالمهمين تم اطلاق
سراحه 63 اسير حرب بينهم اشخاص من فئه
حساسه امكنه تبادلهم بفضل جهود وساطه من
دوله الامارات
يواصل الغرب تضييقه على روسيا حيث اتفق
الاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعه السبع واستراليا
على وضع حد لاسعار المنتجات البتروليه
الروسيه وفي واشنطن اعلن وزير العدل
الامريكي ميريك جارلاند الموافقه على اول
عمليه نقل لاصول مصادره من بعض رجال
الاعمال الروس الى وزاره الخارجيه
لاستخدامها في دعم اوكرانيا تصل الاموال
التي جمدتها واشنطن وحلفائها الى نحو
ثلاثمائه مليار دولار من اصول البنك
المركزي الروسي و30 مليارا من اصول النخبه
الروسيه الخاضعه للعقوبات في المقابل تهدد
موسكو بالرد بمصادره اصول الشركات الغربيه
في روسيا